so I know these aren't the kind of bugs
you probably thought you'd be hearing
about at a programming conference but
today I'm going to talk about how
computing impacts how we as insect
ecologists understand the insect world
and how they impact our environment and
how insect behaviors can actually
inspire software as well and I'm going
to talk about one of the tools that I
made that was inspired by the insects
that I work with so I'm an entomology
PhD student at the University of
Minnesota so I study insects and plants
and plants that eat insects and I've
been a researcher in the field of
biological control of invasive plants
for the last six years and during that
time I got my master's in geographic
information science and that is where I
first was introduced to programming and
learned some programming so I know it
took me that long but I got introduced
to Python and so that's where that
interest started but since I can
remember and everybody knows this about
me I love talking about weevils and
that's because weevils are the cutest
insects they're very charismatic they're
type of beetle called the snap beetle
and you can see why they have these very
modified mouth parts that look like
noses and these are actually uniquely
designed to exploit plants so they all
eat plants and this acorn weevil here
has this modified nose that it's
actually drilled into that acorn and
it's now backed up and is laying an egg
force and egg inside the acorn so that
its babies will hatch and all of their
food will be right there and they're
protected within the seed and so this is
actually a very useful behavior if
there's someone who studies how to
control very problematic invasive weeds
there's almost always a weevil out there
that attacks that specific plant and
we'll talk about why this unique
relationship that they share with plants
means that weevils
are the original functional programmers
so before they have to get into little
background about what biological control
is
and so first we have to talk about what
is an invasive species so an invasive
species is a plant or animal that finds
itself in a novel environment and
usually it's it's facilitated by humans
it's it finds itself in this new area
where it's not native and it does really
really well and it's so successful that
its population gets way out of control
and it starts causing environmental and
economic harm and so at this point we
would consider the species of pest
species and many states actually have
their own laws around regulating peski
shoes and they have to be controlled by
law and so this is a picture in my home
state of Minnesota of Canada thistle
seating out along a federal roadside
there so they have to take measures to
prevent the spread of that population
and we start to consider a biological
control solution when maybe chemical
methods haven't worked so its pest
spraying pesticides is not working it's
resistant or perhaps you can't spray in
sensitive areas that you're trying to
conserve or mechanical means for
preventing the reproduction have failed
and so then you start to consider
bioengineering a solution using a
natural enemy of the pest so this is a
relationship that already existed in its
native land and you're just using it to
your advantage and so this is basically
the end to every Jurassic Park movie
ever that t-rex is like the best bio
control agent and so we like to say in
biological control the simplest way to
put it is the enemy of my enemy is my
friend and the theory is that these a
lot of these pests have become so
problematic because they escaped those
relationships when they got here and so
in my time as a biological control
practitioner of notice there's actually
quite a few parallels to software
engineering and the first is everybody
is excited to get to release day so this
is the day that you get to share all of
your hard work and research and all the
money that you put into your project
with the public and share your solution
with them but the other thing is no
matter how many releases you have people
are only going to remember things
so wrong and so I always this species
always gets brought up when I tell
people what I do so this is Harmonia AXA
Redis or many people notice the Asian
lady beetle and it was introduced for
biological control in the early 1900s to
control an aphid and then more aphids
invaded and it moved north and it gets
into people's houses when it gets cold
but what I like to point out at this
point is that there are tons of
biological control agents that have been
released this is just a catalog of the
ones that have been released for plants
around the world and it's and there's
multiple ones on each page and then
here's one of just insects because you
can have insects for controlling other
insects in North America so the point is
there's been a lot of releases and many
of them there's tons of insects that are
out there doing this work every single
day and you just don't even notice it
and on top of that a lot of things have
changed since the early 1900s when
Harmonia Exodus was released we have a
very strict Quality Assurance process
around selecting a biological control
agent and there's several layers in the
US of federal agencies that oversee this
and so we're specifically focused on
specialist insects so not generalists
ones that depend on the pest species for
their development and we're also of
course looking for something that's
going to be very efficacious on the past
so that it's going to actually regulate
that population and be able to establish
in that new area and it's never going to
eradicate the pests it's just the the
goal is to get them to cycle naturally
in this new environment and just
stabilize the population so it's not
causing so much harm and most of the
agents that are prioritized are
parasitic insects and so when you hear
parasitic insect you might think of a
fly like this farm fly that takes a
blood meal from a mammal and it's very
annoying but this is sort of a very
intermittent intermittent interaction
with its host and ecologists are more
thinking of something like this wasp
that acts
lays its eggs and then the babies are
going to feed on the fly so this is a
very close type of symbiosis but it's
one where one organism benefits and the
other is harmed and so this is what
we're thinking about along the lines of
parasitism it actually depends on the
pest for its development and so I have
some examples of this but some non
entomologists have told me that those
next few slides can be kind of gross if
you don't want to see insects eating
other insects you might just want to
look down if you're squeamish but on the
top there is what we would call the bugs
on bugs worlds those are insects
controlling other insects and the heavy
hitters in this category are definitely
the wasps so wasps have a complete
metamorphosis much like a butterfly
where they're their babies their larval
stage are kind of more me like that and
then they develop and they become what
you think of when you think of a wasp
so that caterpillar in the first picture
has a bunch of floss bags on it that
will hatch and it'll eat them you'll be
happy to know if you don't like spiders
that there's an entire group of wasps
that parasitize spiders there's a
picture of that and then that poor
beetle is parasitized by a wasp as well
and then in the plant world insects they
eat plants or herbivores it's a little
more diverse so that this will seed head
that's an invasive thistle that's being
parasitized you can see some little
worms in there that's actually weevil
Arviso they're babies look like that too
and then if you've ever seen those
little balls on the undersides of leaves
around this time of year those are
actually balls and there's an insect in
there and it's actually an insect that
secretes a mimic hormone into the plant
to trick it into growing a tumor so we
can live inside that tumor and feed and
then the far the caterpillar on the
cactus there is on a prickly pear cactus
it was extremely invasive in Australia
and that is a caterpillar called cactus
tact orem it's the coolest name I've
ever heard for an insect and it was
released to control this cactus in
Australia and they
he erected a monument and its name and
put it on stamps because they were so
appreciative and so before I go and I
also have to state one more special case
of parasitism and that is parasitoid
insects so these are insects that again
will develop on or in a host but they
obligate lead kill the host is part of
this lifecycle so the classic example is
this little parasitic wasp stinging an
aphid she's gonna lay an egg inside and
then that a fit turns into this shell of
what it once was we actually call that a
mummy and that becomes the new case for
the wasp to metamorphosize in so it gets
a meal it turns into a full-blown wasp
and then it's emerging its little head
you can kind of see there from the dead
a-fib and so as you can imagine these
are very valuable biological control
agents because this is very efficacious
and it's also what I'm assuming inspired
the movie alien because that is
definitely a parasitoid lifecycle and so
colleges won't have been wanting to
model these interactions for a long time
to get better understanding of what kind
of control we might see
so typically host pairs to tote host
parasitoid models have a few assumptions
and that is the parasitoids
discontinuously interact with their
hosts so they'll have individual
interactions that will add up to a
greater change in the population and
then both populations will change in
terms of each other if the host
population goes up you will see a rise
in the parasitoid population but then
once they've depleted their resource
they will both go back down as well so
you'll see fluctuations in time with
each other and then this interaction
continues indefinitely so that's either
they're stable coexisting in the field
or they could possibly crash into
extinction and so this is analogous with
solutions that have recurse or problems
that have recursive solutions so with
recursion that usually the problem can
be broken into smaller steps
there's self-reference where the
function is contained within its own
definition and they can also be used to
define
infinite series and so in the early
1900's mathematicians and ecologists
were looking at modeling this type of
special relationship and one of the most
famous models to come from that time
period was the Nicholson Bailey host
parasitoid model and Nicholson was an
ecologist that studied insects and
Bailey was actually a physicist from an
engineering background and so they this
was sort of an interdisciplinary effort
to create the set of recurrence
relations that would describe the
populations and show how they change
over time and I'd like to point out here
that you can actually see that they are
recursive so the host calls the host
population in the previous time step and
the parasitoid function calls the
parasitoid function in the previous time
step and not only that but they're
mutually recursive as well and so just
to explain these other terms and how
that works so the host population
depends upon some growth rate k the host
population that was there before and
then that exponentiated term is how many
hosts escape parasitism that's going to
contribute to their population and with
the parasitoids it's some conversion
efficiency of the host population and
this one minus that term so however many
works so lucky and didn't escape
parasitism and so i wanted to i before i
learned programming i didn't really look
at these equations and think very much
of it but after learning programming i
looked at I was like that's recursive
and so I wanted to try and implement a
recursive solution for Nichols and
Bailey in in Python and so I did and I
put in some test data so the host
population was it was its own function
and the parasitoid population was its
own function and the test data worked as
expected so I as a weed biological
control practitioner wanted to apply
this to my system and so for that you
have to consider
can a rivers insects be really
considered parasitoids they're
definitely parasites because they live
on the plant they're causing some harm
to the plant they're very closely
associated with it a lot of them are
endogenous they develop within the
plants you can see that weevil are vyas
eating it from the inside out and many
of them are special very specialized on
a particular host and they're going to
damage either keep the plant from
getting to a critical growth stage or
they're going to destroy seen and so at
this point I would consider that a type
parasitoid like relationship because
you're taking one individual
reproductive unit away or you're
accruing some biomass for your own
population so the B Nichols so the
recursiveness is going to work out the
same so the math is functionally the
same but if you're going to apply a
Nicholson Bailey style solution you have
to account for all the complex life
history the traits that plants have so
if you're a gardener you know that you
can have annual plants where they're
driven by the seed they produce every
year and come back every year or maybe
you have biennial plants whether they
grow a vegetative state in the first
year and then a flowering adult the
second year so you have to account for
some of those time legs that you're
going to see in the interaction and on
top of that many weeds have soil seed
banks and that's exactly what it sounds
like
that's when seeds can stay in the soil
for a number of years waiting for the
right conditions to germinate so lots of
weeds have this because it's very
advantageous when you get to a novel
environment and you want to wait for
just the right rainfall and the
temperature and everything to emerge and
also so these are some of the things we
have to consider because when we release
a biological control agent for weeds
it's going to take a certain amount of
times before you see control so this
cyclic Leonys weevil was released for
spotted knapweed which is that purple
flower and it invades pastures and
rangelands and that was ten years later
after they took the before and after
picture so when they first released it
an established they didn't see much
control but then ten years later they
started to see this drastic improved
and it was because the seed bank lasts
about ten years so this all has to be
factored factored into a nickels and
Bailey style model and so someone did do
this in two thousand five five Vaughn
Buckley and colleagues came up with this
Nicholson Bailey model for an annual
weed so it was called Patterson's curse
and it's a very pretty flower that
invaded Western Australia but it's it's
not suitable for äj-- for livestock and
for the cattle industry was very upset
by this you can see those cows are
stranded in an area where they can't
really get any food and so they released
a couple weevils and one of them was
mangu lowness larvae TISS which mines
the stem it feeds in the stem of the
plant and they saw a lot of success with
this weevil and so buckley developed
this model kind of post hoc with field
collected data to see if they could use
it to recreate that stable coexistence
that they saw in the field and they just
implemented this imperative lee and they
were able to see that they got a stable
interaction with the two populations
when they modeled it but i wanted to do
this for my system and mine has a few
caveats so i studying a garlic mustard
home it's an invasive species in north
america that invades forests
understories and it's a strict biennial
plant so it forms a vegetative mask
called the rosette in the first year and
then in the second year it sprouts into
this white flower that you see here and
it actually stays green under the snow
and does this right away so it out
competes all of the flowering forest
flowers that people want to see in these
natural areas and it will become
basically the only thing you'll see and
because it also is a seed bank that
lasts up to seven years control is very
difficult you can apply herbicide which
is cheaper but then you're going to be
spraying areas with those species that
you're trying to protect and you can
also get massive amounts of volunteers
and pull it out but you're going to have
to keep pulling
for seven or so years before you
actually deplete the population and so
it was prioritized for biological
control and they went to Europe and they
found several weevils that were actually
feeding on garlic mustard at various
stages so all of these weevils look the
same but I promise you they're different
and they prioritize suturing Kostova
kalus in the corner here that feeds on
the rosette and mines the stem in the
roots of the plant and greatly reduces
its ability to get to the second year
flowering stage and then ideally you
would like to release a weevil that
attacks the flowering stage as well just
in case any escape and get to that point
and so this is suturing Kiska strictest
which the larvae consume one seed and
they can lay multiple larvae and each
seed head but with all of these
interactions going on it's very powerful
for us to be able to abstract a model to
try and get an idea of which agents we
want to prioritize and which ones are
going to be successful either on their
own or together because these can take
years of research you know up to 20
years of research to make sure that
they're specialists and just to
illustrate how complex the different
life cycles interacting this is just
garlic mustard developing as a seed has
to overwinter the rosette stage the
flowering stage and then here's the two
weevils that I mentioned and when they
would attack it so it's a lot easier to
model this and to keep it all in your
head and so that's what I wanted to do I
started out with just a conceptual state
diagram of a one weevil attacking the
stages of the plant and so I started
with suturing Kostova kalus so that's
the one that attacks the first year is
that and this is a picture of them for
scale they're very small about the size
of a peppercorn and they have this
behavior where they play dead when you
disturb them so it makes it really
difficult to find them because as you
can see they're the color of dirt and
they like to hide in the dirt whenever
they sense people coming but they attack
the first year rosette and they seem to
have a lot of power over that stage of
the plan
and so the state diagram ended up being
three separate functions so you know the
seed bank feeds into the rosette
population or rosette feeds in the
flower and the flower feeds back into
the seed bank but then this closed loop
between the weebles suturing Kasturba
kalus and the rosette is the important
part because whatever it takes from
rosette recruits to its own population
is going to feed back into the flowers
and the seed bank over time and so this
set of equations ended up being
developed into a Python package that I
made called generations and it contains
that first Nicholson Bailey equation
test equations that I made in its own
module and then the Buckley equations to
represent the annual weeds so if you
have weed biological control
practitioners that have an annual weed
that's available to as a recursive
equation and then the biennial module as
well that contains new math that I'm
going to talk about for representing
that biennial stage structure and I'm
hoping to finish up soon another module
called double agent at the moment that
incorporates the effects you would get
with having two agents for at least on
one for each stage and so this is just
what the package looks like so the user
gets this config file with all these
default parameters that they can set
with field collected or lab collected
data and then there is a base model
package that's the object-oriented side
of it that's the constructor and all
that it has in it are it's just parsing
the the parameters of the config file so
there's magic method in there for
converting to a float so it can just
feed into the equations as rot inputs so
they can focus on the functional
programming side of things so each of
these modules contains the equations and
there's a memoization
file as well and this since they're all
recursive this just allows them to cache
the last few outputs in memory so it's
not recalculating every time so it
greatly speeds up the process because it
can be
memory costly and so I'm mostly going to
be talking about the biennial section
since this is what I developed
specifically for my system and hopefully
other we'd bountiful researchers that
are working on biennial plants and so
the biennial part of it is actually
mutually recursive itself because you
have the rosette stage in the flowering
adult stage and just to kind of show
that they're both calling the rosettes
are calling the flowers because they
depend on how many flowers were able to
survive and same with the flowers they
depend on how many rosettes survived in
the previous time step and then I had to
incorporate the seed bank as well which
Buckley did a lot of work on this I just
had to incorporate the rosette in there
as well and the seed bank depends on how
many seeds actually stay in the seed
bank so there's some probability of
germination and decay how many seeds
were already there and then there's some
plant density dependence functions where
I had to incorporate the rosette
population that we don't really have to
worry about too much but I should note
that this is very simplified especially
the germination and decay rates because
that's very environmentally dependent
and it's not super informed on those
things but this is just sort of a model
to get the idea of the interaction so
here's just a representation of the seed
bank function I should note that it is
very wordy but I kind of made a choice
with all the parameters to leave them
exactly as they're written out and the
config file just for transparency and so
be very clear for people who don't know
Python if they want to take a look in
there you know what's actually doing
what and then with all of these the base
cases just zero so you specify a certain
amount of years or generations that you
want to run the simulation and it'll
always recurse back to zero and then the
weevil function so this is based on
suturing this robocalls attacking the
rosette again and so you can see that
the weevil function depends on how many
rosettes were there how many weevils
were in the previous time step
weevil survival and attacker eight which
is eggs per weevil per plant and then
there's this exponential function that
Bay
simply describes how many weevils you
can get out of a plant because you can
get multiple larvae but there's a point
of diminishing returns where there's too
many larvae and competition will cause
it to fail so that's just incorporating
that and then here's the part where that
weevil function actually gets linked
recursively with the plant stage so it's
actually on the adult at one point I
switched from F of T so flowering to
adult because it was clearer in my mind
so that's why it's a of T now but the
adult is the one that actually depends
on how many rosettes survive so there's
rosettes in the previous time step and
then there's also this exponential term
which is basically the rate at which
weevils are stealing rosettes for their
own population and stealing that away
from the adult population and so there's
some density dependence and some rates
of energy efficiency conversion in there
as well and so that's just a
representation there was so that's for
functions for defined functions that I
described in the biennial package and
there's their math translations and then
I also recently included a amines for
generating perhaps so a lot of
biocontrol practitioners actually want
to graph this relationship over time and
so I went to a Python meetup and I heard
about bouquet and I thought that was a
really neat package so this is the
graphing package for Python where it
automatically generates an HTML page
with a zoomable graph so you can like
zoom into the different time steps and
everything and so now through that base
model constructor its given all of the
the functional programming modules the
capability of taking a CSV that the
output of all the function outputs and
then graphing it with okay and so I'm
still working on generations it's still
in development you can find me on alpha
Lima juliet on github I've only done two
releases so far so it's in its early
stages but I'm still hoping to do
sensitivity analysis to figure out which
parameters need to be super accurate
when recorded in the field and we know
that it's probably going to be a weevil
attack right so how many eggs they lay
per plant and then I mentioned that I'd
like to get more flexibility with adding
multiple agents so not just looping it
with the with the rosettes but also the
ability to do it with the adult stage
and maybe have multiple agents on one
stage and then I also would like to
incorporate hyper parasitism and so this
is actually when there's a parasitoid of
a parasitoid and it happens quite often
and it really does affect the
interaction it can really stabilize
interactions and actually the weevils do
you have a pierced wood wasp of course
that we know attacks them and there's
likely ones that are going to be here in
North America that will attack them as
well and I would also very much like to
interface with tools that consider
environmental variables and account for
probabilities of emergence giving
environment environmental conditions
because we know that insects and their
development are heavily reliant on
environmental conditions and they can be
key environmental indicators when
something isn't right and so that's why
we should all be concerned about the
dramatic decreases that we're seeing in
insect populations so a lot of these
studies were done in Europe where
there's long term data about insect
populations in natural areas and we're
seeing a drastic decrease in
particularly flying insect populations
this is concerning because this is where
we get our genetic information in our
biological control solutions for our
studies and so we don't know what
behaviors and what valuable solutions
were losing over there and so you know
as the college's so I would argue that
you know just like ecologists can use
the tools that computer scientists come
up with to help understand what's going
on computer scientists also need a
substrate to implement functional
program and in a real-world scenario
and insects can provide those solutions
and so just like in Jurassic Park
computer scientists needed the
ecologists to survive in the end and the
ecologists needed the computer
scientists to get through so it was a
plus plus or a mutualism and that's all
I have I think and so there's I think
there's lots of time for questions and
stuff so I just throw up some references
and then that is actually someone on the
side of the road searching for the
weevils that we did end up using for our
study so they're just pulled over
looking at plants and just an example it
was back in 1998 so that's how long this
this research can take so thank you very
much
[Applause]
yes so the question was when using the
weebles is is the goal to would you say
just to limit yeah so its goal de limit
or and not eradication yes the goal is
to usually get it below what we deem
like an economic threshold and sometimes
that's really easy to calculate if it's
crop species like aphids on soybean and
you can just figure out what yield loss
would you know be the economic threshold
but with our insects it's kind of hard
because it's a conservation issue so
it's not as clear but yeah usually
there's like this this rate of harm that
we determine is kind of critical that we
need to get him below that point before
we start to see like economic benefits
but I will say there's tons of
cost-benefit analyses that have been
done and the benefit to cost ratio is
very high even with all the money that
goes into this research because it is
self-replicating out there and you're
saving tons and human labor and chemical
use so
yes so that's a really good question so
the question was how would this be
changed for to like direct like
predators direct parasitism rather than
a parasitoid relationship and I would
say the bat sees this is like discrete
recursive relations I think that would
be continuous I'm just thinking about
herbivores but there are or before
central East that just continuously do
foliate the plant until like all year
until it's it can't photosynthesize
anymore and I would imagine you'd have
to do like some calculus and go for a
continuous relationship model would be
my guess which I'm afraid of so I
haven't done but they exist I I recently
went to a conference and someone was
working on that for an insect that
defoliated an invasive water hyacinth so
yeah
yes that's a good question yes so the
question was at what's the goal is it
just to keep up with the pace the rate
of things invading or is there kind of a
longer term effort
there's definitely we definitely focus
on prevention first so there's all kinds
of programs out there for preventing the
spread like Leave No Trace or if you've
ever heard of this stop aquatic
hitchhikers program so there's more laws
being put in place for prevention
because we know that once a species
reaches and establishes here it's very
hard to get control and lasting control
but I would say that that's that's a
very underdeveloped area it's like most
people are focusing on okay what do we
do now and just trying to keep up rather
than how do we like stop them from
actually getting through to this new
area so yeah it's very underdeveloped
and would take a lot of networks and
systems research I think so we need
programmers Thanks thank you for
confirming that weevils are the cutest
insect I've been saying it for years no
one believes me
um my question is do these types of
equations also apply to non insects
parasitoids like cordyceps or anything
like that
oh yeah that's a good question
yes so there's an entire field for so I
think one section I think this last
section here is all for pathogens so
there's definitely an entire field for
just researching biological control
agents just using pathogens I know
Canada thistle that one that I mentioned
there's a pathogen for that and and
people have used Nichols and Bailey
style equations to model that but yeah I
haven't thought about how it abstract to
those systems yet it's a very difficult
it's even more difficult than the insect
on plant world because there's a lot of
regulations around releasing plant
pathogens and it's hard to get control
before it like dies out and the plant
becomes resistant so but that would be a
very interesting application I think for
sure
in a controlled environment yes so the
question was do we rear the insects that
we're releasing in a controlled
environment and we typically do so most
of the insects I showed in that picture
that fed on garlic mustard some of them
are eliminated just because they didn't
rear well in the lab so yes we were rear
ours in the lab and then we typically
will do like releases and strategic ways
and then some programs have even scaled
up to the point where they like get
release kits to people because you this
this sort of modeling might also help us
understand how many we should release to
in a particular area given the size of
it and everything like that so yep that
would definitely be next steps for us
it's not approved for release yet it
isn't Canada and we're still going
through several layers of bureaucracy in
North America which is good it's good
that it's there but yes that would be
kind of the next step constants with the
number of constants involved and the
non-linearity of the equations I would
think would be just unbelievably hard to
zero in on the exact you know settings
of constants that would get you the
kinds of behavior that you're seeing in
the wild
I could imagine doing this and being
able to play around until you had
successfully model something that was
already out there but if you're trying
to predict the behavior of something
you're talking about putting out there
how do you even begin to do that so
that's exactly what I talked about with
Yvonne Buckley the one who did that
annual model because they were trying to
model something that
already occurring in the field and
that's very difficult to do given all of
the different things that are going on
out there and they had to really kind of
adjust parameters to actually produce
what they were seeing and so that's
that's a challenge that we think about a
lot we know that the attack rate of the
weevils is extremely variable and like
we have no idea why they choose to lay
like 20 eggs on this one stem and not
the other so there's all these cues that
they have that we aren't aware of but I
think the main thing that I would like
to see it used for is just to get an
understanding of which combination of
weevils or are you going to get enough
control of one weevil do you need more
than one weevil just sort of
comparatively rather than predicting
what we'd actually see in the field
because there's also the possibility
that they wouldn't establish for
whatever reason you know environmentally
so did that answer your question kind of
it does I am I'm curious when you're
thinking about releasing a new insect
what sort of steps you take to figure
out ahead of time whether introducing
that will change the balance and some
other unexpected way and cause a
cascading reaction sort of thing okay
yes so that's the majority of my work
and I love talking about it so we have
this long process of host range testing
where you know for our plant garlic
mustard we get every native plant that's
a representative from every Lake native
plant that's closely related in that
same tribe and we force the weevils on
them in the lab and we test them and so
they're in this controlled facility this
bio containment facility they can't get
out we grow the plants we bring them in
and we test them in all these plants
we've done 114 we also test crop plants
even if they're not related at all and
then plants that grow in similar
habitats and things like that and we
tested hundreds and they only develop on
garlic mustard we determined they're
specialists
and so that's how the process works now
in the past like 50 years ago 100 years
ago it was just
we're in trouble we need to release
something and they would release
generalists and then you'd get those
unexpected behaviors so just I kind of
tend to go back to what she was saying
have you seen in the instance and it's
only I guess been 20 years or so but
we're a plant mutates to the weave let's
you release on it and so the plants are
adapting to the weevils themselves Oh
developing resistance we see that more
with the release of the pathogens there
because it's very quick to develop
resistance to pathogens typically with
the insects that relationship is usually
pretty well established I would say that
more what's often the case is that
there's a possibility the plant like
garlic mustard for example has been here
for hunt for over a hundred years and
there's a possibility that it's changed
a lot and it's biology once it's gotten
here and they won't establish on it so
it would probably they probably died out
pretty quickly in most cases if that
were to occur but yeah hopefully that
answers your question
so I think do we have time for one more
are we good one more okay yeah so just
to piggyback on his question is does the
other kind of evolution happen where you
have a specialist and you introduce them
and then they evolve into more of a
generalist they find something similar
and spread that way yeah so that is
definitely something we think about and
worry about and that's why we do all the
host range testing we do know that with
the host range testing and then field
studies afterward that their niche
the sort of section of plants that they
feed on it's pretty stable so I'm not
saying that couldn't ever happen there's
always a risk there's a risk to
everything that you do pesticides and
everything that we do but but some of
the studies after the fact have found
that their niche was actually pretty
stable from what we viewed in the lab
but that research is always ongoing like
you know reviewing host range testing
other biocontrol researchers reviewing
their own test range testing and stuff
and looking back on it 20 years so very
cool thank you okay thank you everybody
[Applause]